let me jump to this story here from
louder with credor.com
uh crowder's been suspended guys uh so
uh we don't know why crowder doesn't
know exactly why it was his interview
with carrie lake we've had her on the
show several times we've not had these
issues we've talked about a whole lot
crowder team crowder writes ladies and
gentlemen the orwellian centers at
youtube are at it again this time
they've chosen to not only target louder
with crowder but to silence republican
republican gubernatorial candidate
carrie lake our interview with the
arizona gubernatorial candidate has been
removed from youtube over their alleged
misinformation policy
crowder is unable to live stream on
youtube for the next two weeks what
specifically ran a file the policy only
youtube knows
but our lawyer william richmond will be
getting answers we'll share with you on
the show thursday august 18th there will
be a show and this is really important
guys uh if if you guys are uh you know
typically tune in to crowder
now you know make sure you tell
everybody what happened because
they're having shows i'm assuming
they're they're gonna be putting them up
on rumble rumble.com
steven crowder and uh
welcome to the midterms everybody
we this was good we knew this was gonna
get crazy who did we have on we just
told us it was gonna get really crazy
was it naomi wolfe yeah i think it was
naomi she was like it's gonna get yeah
that was a good episode too that's gonna
get crazy
yeah you think there's suspending
crowder it they're gonna they're gonna
do everything they can to try and
diminish the voice of those who oppose
the establishment they don't like that
liz cheney lost they're going after alex
jones they're trying to indict donald
trump they just took crowder down for
two weeks off youtube
that matters
real quick you know what you know why
youtube matters 95 percent of gen z say
says they use youtube it is the pre is
the dominant platform for the younger
generation that's right this is where
people need to be to be reaching the
younger generation being forced on a
rumble rumble's great i like rumble but
it's not where the younger generation is
yeah this is what uh jordan peterson was
saying years ago when he was asked why
he was going on youtube and doing videos
instead of writing articles or something
and he was like i wanted to reach the
most people so that's why i went on
youtube do you think they're going to
indict trump i think they are absolutely
they really are absolutely going to they
are going to have to now i guess here's
the thing here's the thing
washington dc there is no justice in
washington dc the d.c justice system has
been co-opted so much by the left that i
do not doubt for one freaking second
that merrick garland is going to find a
corrupt
corrupt grand jury in dc that is going
to unseal corrupt indictments on donald
trump that for crimes that he never
committed i absolutely believe that 100
because they want to stop him they know
they've seen the polls showing that he
is beating joe biden in 2024 and they
want to stop him and this is the way
that they're going to do it but it's not
going to work out it's not i don't think
it's going to work what are they going
to indict them on they're going to find
something they're they've said they
weren't going to do it because uh it's a
step over the line they would just
dangle it in front of everybody like oh
we did a search warrant that proves he's
a criminal that's what they're saying
and they wouldn't cross that line but
now what people are saying and i'm
starting to agree because i'm look i'm
not entirely sure is that the move
against trump was so egregious they have
no choice but to lean into it otherwise
it just looks political so they have to
come up with something to justify why
they did they have spent six years
searching for a crime yeah in every
other and trying to fabricate some well
yeah they fabric you know they
fabricated evidence to justify spying on
trump and kevin kleinsmith i believe his
name is uh received a one-year probation
sentence
and not only that but he got his law
he's now has his law license backed by
the dc bar in good standing that's crazy
and then there's the then there's the
other fbi lawyer what the the guy who
just got acquitted what the heck's his
name he got he he he altered evidence in
an email to j he also he was another guy
who altered evidence to justify spying
and he just got acquitted for it he even
though it was in his crime was in
writing and a dc jury that consisted of
two hillary clinton donors and a woman
whose daughter went to school with his
daughter
voted to acquit him
the guy's name escapes or michael
sussman that was that's right that's
right and but that's how justice works
in dc if you lie in fisa warrants to
justify illegal spying on your political
opponents you'll get acquitted by a jury
of your donors if you're steve bannon
and you get held in contempt by an
illegitimate congressional committee
they will put you in jail that's how
that's how justice works in dc and
that's why i absolutely think they're
going to indict trump
and then what happens
i mean we're already we we've already
had so much crazy stuff happen in the
past week or so with just the outrage
i mean the guy in ohio for instance a
cincinnati fbi office
what happens didn't he go in with a nail
gun wasn't it because people think that
nail guns can get through bulletproof or
something like that is it not that's not
a thing one of the things that happens
is people turn on tv find out what's
going on and they find shows like this
so it's up to us in a lot of ways people
are kind of well they turn on youtube
changing the tone of the narrative and
tone is big right now
that's why everyone's coming down i know
i don't i don't know what will happen
but what would i travel what i do know
is i think it's going to light an effing
fire under the gop base
yes that's
absolutely what it's going to do i saw a
meme that showed a ship that said mog on
it sinking and a bunch of rats wearing
mug hats were like panicked and swimming
away from it i don't think that they're
all laughing and then i i responded with
with the poll showing that trump's
actually his polling's improved since
the fbi raid and then they were all just
like all the lefties got depressed like
no really it's like bro you guys have no
idea what's going on do you like well
they haven't had any ideas i'm not going
to walk away from trump just because the
fbi is going after him they're going to
rally behind him right and they haven't
had any idea what's going on since 2016.
i mean you remember 2016
the entire media was like the trump
voter who is this trump voter who are
these people
and they still have not figured out
who the trump voters are or why or why
people are so opposed to the going
narrative and the uh the current regime
and there's and i'll say this there's
only one crime that donald trump has
ever committed only one and that's
beating hillary clinton yeah that is
that was a crime he was never supposed
to do that and they have never been able
to come to terms with that and so
they've that that is his only crime
that's the crime that they're that that
they want to take him down for and
they're trying to do it i was watching a
documentary on the nazis last night and
and basically after the first world war
the treaty versailles
annihilated germany took all this
territory put them in massive amounts of
debt so they felt hopeless and when
people feel hopeless they look for a
leader a strong leader to help get them
out of the trouble when you look at the
way people have been persecuted the last
two years and been driven insane with
covet
uh stuff i think that people are like
beginning i'm afraid that people may s
they snag on to a strong man that is
give gives them hope uh gives them a
political you know i don't want to see
another hitler rise to power they've
been like afraid of trump and saying
like he's hitler he's like don't turn
him into hitler don't do that to people
don't destroy their hope and their their
will to live because they will look for
a strong man if you do
we just
look at the past bro you see that video
this woman from fox posted it
where she's like this is what it's like
when you get to work at 3am
oh my goodness yes i didn't wait i
didn't i didn't i didn't see this people
fighting in the streets all over the
place it's new york city and it's people
just beating the hell out of each other
in the street out the window
it's not one fight it's like a bunch of
fights all over the place it's a bunch
of people freaking out on each other
that was i found that terrifying in part
because okay february 2019 or february
2020 before the pandemic before
everything
went crazy i was perfectly happy to walk
around new york city at three o'clock in
the morning nothing like that was ever
happening you never saw that
well now it's normal now you have open
air now markets and homeless cities well
like screw eric adams like he ran
like he ran on cleaning this crap that's
why he won that's why he won yeah that
is literally why he won and instead he's
focused on
he's focused on going to texas to
campaign against greg abbott because
he's anything
he put up billboards in florida about
like how gay people are welcome in new
york as if anybody in the world didn't
know that
still lives in new york i mean you've
got a question i don't know oh my god
no pressure libby
we've been telling libby to get out of
there for a while move moved i live in
virginia virginia's great we have a
republican governor we have the state
the only the only state uh body that's
going to contribute virginia is better
west virginia okay i agree with that
yeah
but i really quite like west virginia
but yeah it's beautiful it's gorgeous
but move chickens if you can little
rolling hills yeah the lush greenery you
go up on the mountain and there's like
chickens just like everywhere wow like
they're not like quite literally like
walking around you mean outside chicken
city they've escaped or they're just
colonizing when you go into the
neighborhoods in west virginia into like
the communities if you're just like
driving down the road chickens are like
yeah just out i had to get out of the
car and usher one off the street so i
didn't i was in new hampshire recently
we were driving around and new hampshire
is
also very beautiful and we're driving
around new hampshire and we had to stop
short for a whole mess of turkeys to
cross the street it's so awesome isn't
it great getting away from these awful
cities where people are beating the crap
we rented like a little house that had a
pool
crazy not only do they get the crap
eaten out of each other but they'll get
out of jail the next day be from a soros
funded prosecutor that's correct there's
also another video people ransacking at
mcdonald's you see this one yeah dude
wait did you see the one where it was
like
it was like some sort of like late night
snack stand that these like three women
the fries thing yeah the fries these
three like black women just trashed the
plates that was insane it was over the
cost of french fries
sauce it was
cost extra for sauce and these drunk
chicks just they like jumped up they
were like twerking on the counter yeah
and they were like just throwing cr like
that's not like the stuff's happening
all over though that that bodega owner
who uh yeah jose jose alba because a
woman came in complaining about the
price of oh no this is a different story
and then no
yeah woman came in complaining about the
price of chips or something had a knife
he said get out she comes out with her
boyfriend they start fighting she stabs
the store owner he stabs the guy while
they're fighting he gets arrested they
let him out he fled didn't i think he
went back well didn't puerto rico or no
no no no caribbean
yeah somewhere in the caribbean didn't
they like for a short time take his
passport away too i don't know because
they put they they they had him murder
charges they put him in rikers yeah they
put him in riker like in
you're not allowed to talk about how
george soros spends a lot of money to
elect he is our culture has collapsed
it's all look
it used to be that people had scruples
and wanted to do what was right it used
to be that when someone committed a
crime they'd be like we gotta stop this
and try and make sure the society can
function these days it's just like don't
know don't care tilt to a judge
that's what you get i remember i got
pulled over when i was like 18
and kappa said i was speeding i wasn't
speeding and he just says i don't care
talk to a judge and that like that's the
way it is they don't know you they don't
care about you and if your life is
ruined that was in chicago that guy's
trying to fill his quota for the month
of school chicago is so crooked yeah i
got my license suspended and then i
couldn't drive for a couple years oh my
goodness because chicago is as corrupt
as they come in you know i really hate
chicago i really really despise the
place and i try to avoid going there it
is i've been to so many places around
the world i would rather be in like a
brazilian favela than chicago chicago
operated black sites where they would
kidnap people and torture them there was
a famous that for a long time there was
a guy who was electrocuting people into
forced confessions that's right i've had
such crazy stuff happen to me in chicago
i'm just like bro you do not want it and
i've never been to chicago i feel the
same way about my home city as well i'm
from philadelphia philadelphia has
become a mess like oh you're from philly
yeah i went to high school in
philadelphia where'd you go to high
school uh germantown friends oh really
yeah nice i went to the holy ghost proud
oh nice yeah um
but uh
no but there was like philadelphia you
see a crazy murder story coming out of
philadelphia at least like once a day
like i remember there was one last week
or the week before there was this guy
who grew up in philly and he moved to
las vegas and he came home to attend a
friend's funeral who had been shot and
killed because that's a thing that
happens in philly every single day
because we have a corrupt soros-funded
district attorney and a terrible mayor
and this guy came home to attend his
friend's funeral who got shot and killed
and he proceeded to get shot and killed
oh my goodness as he was visiting home
and yet so like and and like the mayor
has just become a ridiculous person jim
kenny who's the mayor of philadelphia
you may remember when he shut down
indoor dining in the city and then
proceeded to go to a get caught going to
a restaurant in new jersey but he after
after the remember the fourth of july
shooting that happened that was crazy it
was right on the it was right on the
parkway yeah so the fireworks were going
on and there was a shooting like as the
fireworks were happening so it was just
complete chaos but they interviewed jim
jim kenny goes on local news after this
and lily just says he i'm not even
joking he says i am looking forward to
not being here anymore and it's like
he really wanted out it's like screw you
dude if you're not willing to deal with
the realities of crime in your city what
the [ __ ] are you the mayor
yeah why is he the mayor if he doesn't
want to actually but what sucks is
they're going to elect another mayor
just like him probably doing it
yes you just got to leave they need
frank or his opponent i mean
polarization the other eye could he get
worse like the other option is militant
like militants like more cops on the
street
you know what kind of right so in the
early 90s when giuliani came in to fix
up new york city
um there were more cops like the
difference was so transparently clear it
was sort of amazingly clear so i used to
hang out in washington square park it
was always a total disaster you know you
walk through the park whatever
everyone's offering you drugs every five
minutes you know as you walk through the
park
uh almost overnight there was a big
mobile police unit at the bottom of the
park
um on washington square south there were
cops everywhere and suddenly you weren't
getting offered drugs anymore you'd walk
like all through downtown and it was you
know people just kept getting pushed out
to the edges pushed out to the edges
finally giuliani moved the entire red
light district out to queens which
hasn't been great for queens admittedly
um
but yeah it changed overnight giuliani
cleaned up the city and then bloomberg
came in and paid for everything and the
city was great after that what do you
mean paid for everything um well we had
we had a low crime city
so he was able to get a lot of
investment in he was able to get a lot
of businesses to come back in
then he used all that tax money to fund
big parks projects so he built up the
outer boroughs he did this massive parks
program
and it was really nice yeah i support
large-scale police activity if it's done
judiciously they did stop
what is like an insanely sad thing to me
happening in america since the summer of
love that occurred in 2020 is
from like the 1990s to like through the
the 2010s
violent crime in america consistently
went down like you wouldn't see that
like if you followed the media which
constantly likes to elevate this [ __ ]
you wouldn't see that but violent crime
in america went down for two decades and
it has gone back up over the last three
years because
liberal da's have decided to not enforce
the law in order to appease rich radical
progressive activists who don't have to
deal with the realities of the policies
that they advocate for but the people
who are hurt by this and the reason eric
adams won is because poor you know
working class middle working class
people in new york city who actually
have to deal with the realities of crime
every day voted for him because he was
the tough on crime candidate and
obviously he hasn't done that which has
been a major disappointment but we are
literally reversing decades of a
decrease in violent crime in order to
appease the worst elements of our of of
our society and it's an incredibly sad
thing cities once great american cities
like chicago and like philadelphia are
being destroyed once and it's the
saddest thing ever about philadelphia i
don't know about chicago it was it's
been run by the mob for over 100 years
well i'm just saying like ours we have
great cities like you know we need like
we have great cities and they're being
destroyed by this ideology i'll tell you
chicago is great awesome the mafia right
like some of the greatest stories about
the old bank robbers and stuff really
bad stuff really horrifying stuff but it
creates a a legend and a mythos around
the city that makes it some somewhat
interesting but uh
chicago's reputation is and always has
been pure corruption okay maybe chicago
you know why they call it the windy city
because there's a lot of wind because
the politicians are blowing hot air
because it is very windy
it's actually not that's actually no i
thought it was windy really no yeah i
lived there three years i've only been
to chicago sometimes because you have a
lake yeah it's like not particularly
windy it's it's it's like maybe slightly
above average but you wouldn't and it's
something all of people in chicago know
it's called the windy city because the
politicians are lying that's what it is
okay but maybe chicago is a bad example
but like los angeles san francisco
no but like like hollywood iconic
american cities that have contributed so
much to our culture you can't walk in la
anymore without stepping on a freaking
needle or in human places i i do
understand that point but i also got to
point out you know i i talk about this
news article i was reading from uh it
was at glenn beck's studio it's from
like 1870 or something it was about a
guy who was at a bar some guy walked up
to him and put a put a pistol to his
chest and pulled the trigger like it was
way worse
crime
was like way worse you would just die
and you stubbed your toe and you get an
infection it's gotten way better the
issue is it's it's getting relatively
worse from where it was it it was really
really bad it got really good and now
it's getting bad again and we're not
okay with it and we shouldn't be
no we had a standard of living in this
country in our cities and regression but
it has declined but like what's going to
happen is the people who have the means
to you are going to leave these cities
and that's and they take their the tax
base goes away and the people that get
hurt the most are low-income people who
are who can't who don't have the means
to move and are forced to deal with the
realities of this every single day we
need new cities i think too so people
leaving like that whole what is it iron
thing where all these people went
started a new city i like that idea
because you can start at high tech well
yeah we have great we still have great
cities in america that people can move
to
like was that galtz gulch
yeah like uh cuyahoga falls ohio for
instance phenomenal city on the river
all the rich people all the all the mer
people of great merit also even make our
own secrets well and no one has to go to
work anymore everyone should just work
in there all the rich people can just
work in their house and we just started
amazon drone deliveries did you buy your
metaverse land package yeah we just
start would you start communes of people
leaving leaving crime in cities they did
that right you know like new harmony
yeah but you know what's really fun look
something that i learned recently that i
thought was pretty wild is that it is
now more expensive to live in miami than
new york city and it's not because of
like the crazy housing policies they
have in new york city it's because so
many people are moving there like west
palm beach which is where my company is
based out of and where most of my
co-workers live in order to qualify for
a single apartment by yourself you need
to have they they say that they like the
minimum salary per year you need to have
is like over a hundred thousand dollars
which is like the top like two percent
of income earners thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you